after everything you've been through so
what do you say they distance themselves
they distance so what do you say to the
people who distance themselves from you
shame on you
shame on you
after what i did for you for your
children helped you make a lot of money
and
you couldn't come to visit me
for eight and a half months
you couldn't send a card
a letter i was getting mail from
children
in other countries
and somehow
12 and 13 year old little girls were
finding the correct address they were
getting their cards and letters to me
and
people here that i
taught their children before a
television show they were very happy
customers before dance moms and then
during it they were stars they were
making money they were on top of the
world
and you're just gonna dump me
it's
not hurtful anymore
because you realize real quick who your
friends are real quick is it also less
hurtful just knowing how far you've come
and everything you've overcome as well
you know is that yes it is it is and
isn't i i mean
i don't know how you don't give credit
to someone they all
all of them
all the kids all the moms
act as if
i had nothing to do with the show nor my
studio well my friend
john carolla created the show it was his
idea when he saw my kids and met them in
vegas so
i don't know how this would have
happened in another dance studio about
you
well without my building in my studio
and then flying into pittsburgh they
interviewed not auditioned keep that in
mind they interviewed 30 families for
the show they did 27 were my students at
my studio
two were friends of mine that had little
boys that i thought were hilarious and
one was kathy
who was also a colleague of mine
so
if they would have gone to another
studio down the street or an hour away
from me how would they have even known
about it that's it's all about gotta
start somewhere right yes
and the kids block it out and they
forget and oh it was toxic blah blah
blah well let's go back to pittsburgh
i'll show you the house she used to live
in and then we'll go see the house you
live in now that part
you remember that happening look at
abby's got receipts abby's got receipts
yes
you remember those bags of money you
were bringing home yeah
well
i'll all remind you of what it was let's
talk about the uh gofundme that you're a
part of yes you're right okay so there
is uh it's feeding the children correct
why was it important for you to attach
yourself to this initiative teaching
children all around the world on zoom
just
the other day
i was asking them what the easter bunny
was going to bring
and
they all said money
i i didn't understand that but i guess
in the plastic eggs you get the
dollars and the coins and stuff so
i'm thinking here you kids are and i say
this all the time to the children
you are lucky
be grateful
you are healthy
your mom and dad can afford for you to
take these lessons you go to these
competitions you wear these expensive
costumes be grateful when i found out
about katarina's club and what bruno
serato was doing
i had to be a part of it
uh gloria gainers involved
you know there's a lot of housewives
that are involved and
what better thing to do what better
charity could i be involved in than
feeding children
i mean come on
so feed the kids initiative how can
people at home get involved feed the
kids initiative i'm going to be posting
on my instagram and they can go there
and there's a link so that they can go
right to it and get involved there's
also katerine's club there's bruno
serato there's a lot of ways you can
find out about it but i want to reach
out to the children you have been making
an impact on so many children's lives
for so long i actually want to talk to
you about one of your students jojo siwa
yes you know she recently revealed that
she wasn't invited to the kids choice
awards and you know a lot there was no
reason given but some fans
believed that maybe it was because she
recently came out and it was her
sexuality what did you make of that i
didn't think that and i don't know why
she aired all that i i would have
gone and done something else that night
you know as a child growing up
i was heavy
and
kids are cruel
people are cruel and this in this town
it's tough so
my mom
or dad would flip it if i came home from
school crying or upset i wasn't invited
to this birthday party or this boy asked
another girl
we were like my mom and dad were like oh
you know phooey on them who cares okay
we're gonna do this we're going away
that weekend anyway so you couldn't have
gone to the party anyway so i don't know
why she didn't just flip it around uh
she's been good to them they've been
good to her so i really don't know what
the problem was i just know that
that kid
is a workaholic have you talked to her
have you talked to jojo recently
yes yeah she was just commenting on
something on my instagram uh you know
she's a busy kid she makes work she
creates work for herself to do
when we were shooting a television show
and all those kids were on the bus
playing with each other's hair and
talking about boys jojo
was on that computer
she was uploading her own youtube uh
videos she was doing this she was doing
that she was hustling she was hustling
back yeah yes yes and now looking at her
journey what do you think because
obviously i don't think any of us could
have predicted the type of impact she
was going to make especially since
coming out because now she's reaching a
whole demographic of kids who i feel
like you know are underrepresented on
shows on nickelodeon for example so
absolutely you know absolutely uh it's
funny i used to always
say to the girls
one in six i would tease them
if they were doing something goofy you
know just little girls falling off and i
would say one in six girls one in six
one and six are going to be yeah one and
six yes
so so she's the one she was the one i
was right she was the one you know and
uh she's i mean come on a household name
but every story you walk into
uh and and it's not going to stop it's
going to change
and it's going to
you know flip the switch do you feel
like it's changing now yes yes i do but
hey if i was 18 years old and i had
already made her kind of money i'd never
have to work again i could teach
children all over the world for free
i could that's what i would do but
that's not what she wants to do right no
no she's going to manage kids show her a
record label she'll be doing everything
i love it what do you think of the new
haircut
well
uh-huh i'm a firm believer in the long
hair right because
you can put it in a bun you can put it
in a ponytail you can bring dance
if one of my competition kids
got that haircut
they they wouldn't they sign a contract
they can't change their hair from the
beginning of the season to the end
uh well when you have that put when
you've had that ponytail as long as
she's had i feel like it at some point
you're going to want to just chop it off
absolutely and
her hair was damaged
from
dying it from the product in it from
pulling it back although she's never
gonna have wrinkles and from uh just the
glitter in it and all that stuff so i do
think it needed cut and it's so much
easier on your hairs right i was
completely bald
so i know
how easy it is so as someone who has
lost her hair due to chemotherapy what
was your reaction to the whole will
smith oscar slap and that joke
to clarify
i didn't really lose my hair like that
my friends cut it out
when you go through chemo there's
something some substance whatever that
comes out of your pores
and it goes in you know in your hair and
it makes it sticky and weird and
that's what was going on with my hair
because when i went into the hospital i
had a clip in it and it was up and from
laying on the bed
actually they just cut the whole entire
thing out
it was going to go anyway exactly i'm
blaming my friends for cutting it out
all right but so you had no hair no no
you had no hair no and and for a woman
who had a lot of hair it was traumatic
it was
awful
but i was laying in a hospital room
getting chemo 24 hours a day i was
getting lumbar injections
and i was getting spinal taps i had a
lot more to worry about than my hair
uh
i
i don't know what to say i was at debbie
allen's new studio which is in shonda
rhimes performing arts center right
that's why i was there
and
i was talking to debbie and then out of
the elevator came jada pinkett smith
and
it was like a whirlwind it was like and
she came like right over to me and she
had this
stunning gold metallic
dress on
some strange concoction it was beautiful
and
i was like oh my goodness hello and she
was like hello and
we started to talk
right about the hair really
absolutely right away right immediately
and so i don't know maybe her daughter
was a fan of the show i'm thinking or
whatever but
that was it
and we were standing right in front of
the will smith room
that he donated
at the shonda rhimes performing arts
center
so it was all very surreal well let me
ask you this do you feel like chris
rock's joke warranted that slap no
nothing warrants hitting another person
i've been
physically assaulted myself while on the
tv show
so
i know what that's all about it's scary
it's hurtful it's shocking uh and
chris rock actually has been in my dance
studio and i taught his daughter
privates wow yes acrobatics yes and he's
a great guy of course i made him sit
there he had to get a pen he had to
write everything down he was like why
why why yeah he was great how did jada
seem at that event by the way because
that was her first like public
appearance it was she was like a
whirlwind of gold lemay just
she was there for the duration she was
there uh
humbly
accepting praise for the the donations
that they made and uh
she was herself you know the show must
go on
[Music]